and now is the time to learn who the
winner is for best song and to tell you
here's the sensational young yale
student and star of flash dance who
single-handedly made torn sweatshirts
into high fashion and the computer
genius of war games broadway's tony
award winner and currently the star of
brighton beach memoirs there are miss
jennifer beals and mr matthew broderick
three films produced tonight's nominated
songs one a film about a young woman in
whom the urge to dance becomes a need to
dance then there was a motion picture
about country music and the people who
make it
and third the story of a determined
young girl in turn of the century europe
the song nominees are flash dance what a
feeling from flash dance music by
giorgio marotta lyric by keith forsey
and irene kara
maniac
also from flash dance music and lyric by
michael sambello and dennis mccoskey
over you from tender mercies music and
lyrics by austin roberts and bobby hart
papa can you hear me from yento music by
michelle legrand lyric by marilyn and
alan bergman
and the way he makes me feel from yenta
music by michelle legrand lyric by allen
and marilyn bergman
and the winners are
giorgio marotta keith forcing iron cara
for flashdance what appealing
it's so wonderful to be receiving lisa
this most precious honor from jennifer
beals whose performance in the film made
it that much more special
i
hope i can read this
our brilliant composer georgia moroda is
not with us today but i'm sure he's as
overwhelmed as
myself and keith forsey um
i'd like to thank the members of the
academy
my
terrifically talented cholerasis keith
forsey for making uh
writing so imaginative and beautiful and
so much fun uh
for me personally there there are so
many people to thank um
just to be nominated with the likes of
allen and marilyn bergman and michelle
legrand is
is an honor enough
but let me begin with my parents who are
here tonight
uh weren't for them i would not be here
tonight i'd like to thank
my manager and dearest friend selma
rubin whose
love and guidance and her family for 14
years of supporting me
has helped so much
uh the producers and directors adrian
lynn
paramount pictures polygram happy go day
al corey from network records
oh my teachers uh al greiner phil black
and countryman
jojo smith eve collier
there aren't enough words to express my
love and my gratitude
and last but not least a very special
gentleman
who i guess started it all for me many
years ago
to alan parker wherever you may be
tonight
i thank you
what more can i say but
thank you very much